un nouveau guide alimentaire canadien se
fait toujours attendre vous savez
pourtant il suscite déjà pas mal la
contreverse ya une version préliminaire
qui circulent et qui laisse présager de
grands bouleversements notamment avec la
disparition du groupe alimentaire ne
connaissait très bien dans les produits
laitiers ont faire le point avec sylvain
charlebois professeur et distribution et
politique agroalimentaire à l'université
dalhousie qu'on retrouve donc l'album
bonjour monsieur charlebois charlebois
bonne année à vous et c'est quand même
un gros virage non les produits des tic
il faut dire ne vont pas disparaître du
guide alimentaire canadien
mais il occupait quand même une place de
choix oui à la fête est un quart du
bénin vous savez on connaît la carence
yale des groupes alimentaires les quatre
groupes dont les produits laitiers et là
on a appris cette semaine que tout d'un
coup là les produits laitiers vont
représenter vont être un permis 28
produits alimentaires alors on voi
vraiment là que les besoins les produits
laitiers vont jouer un moins grand rôle
au sein du nouveau guide les rumeurs
évidemment sont véridiques là évidemment
on s'attend à quelque chose de tout à
fait différent au prg et en 2019 bon
le gouvernement qui dit que ce sont des
versions préliminaires la qui circulent
en ce moment on verra justement pourquoi
gouvernement change d' approche selon
vous mais je sentais gardes ont fait
extrêmement attention vous savez le
lobby du lait est extrêmement puissant
et depuis la publication des principes
de base en octobre 2010
vous savez on vous attendait un guide en
2018 2019
et il a raison pourquoi que on attend
toujours le guide ce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de visites à voir j'ai
l'impression pour justement signifier
l'importance des produits laitiers
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on quand on
veut se démarquer je suis senti qu'un
don voit offrir un guide qui va servir
aux canadiens ou du de stimuler
l'économie agricole parce que depuis
1942 le guide alimentaire si ce que ça
fait on veut faire la promotion de
produits canadiens on veut stimuler
l'économie agricole et là tout d'un coup
on veut changer un peu de cas chez santé
canada bon pensez vous que santé canada
va faire marche arrière et deuxièmement
je savoir est ce que le fait de pour
trouver une catégorie produits laitiers
ça peut vraiment faire mal à l'industrie
basse c'est une autre tuile qui tombe
sur la tête du secteur laitier vous
savez il ya eu trois enfants trois
accords signés récemment avec d'autres
continents d'eau pays qui permet des
produits laitiers
pour alex heure d'arrivée au canada on
parle d'une perche au sein du de la
gestion de l'eau la gestion de l'offre
le presser de basse et de produits ce
qu'on a besoin au canada et la menace
on dit sur le point de voir peut-être un
guide qui va décourager les canadiens de
construire des produits laitiers alors
c'est certain que youn inquiétude qui
est palpable au sein de la filiale adia
canadienne j'ai l'impression se dégrada
et et va aller de l'avant avec quelque
chose de tout à fait différent c'est bon
à suivre donc un autre défi pour santé
canada c'est le contrôle des produits
alimentaires à base de cannabis ça s'en
vient l'égalisation 17 octobre 2019
parce qu'on est prêt pour l'instant on
fait juste avant les fêtes vous savez
michel ont présenté un cadre
réglementaire pour les produits
comestibles à base de cannabis et
c'était dans la gazette officielle du 22
décembre
pendant que tout le monde leur lait de
poule et était dans un état festif sans
égale à travailler très fort de 60 jours
mène pour commenter sur le calme de
façon générale le procureur surprise je
pense que ça qu'est santé canada y va
avec beaucoup de prudence
on adopte une approche très
conservatrice jeu santé canada mais
c'est les produits pour attirer des
jeunes qui semble être un peu ambigu le
direct par rapport à son vent pêcher les
entreprises devant des produits qui va
attirer les gens mais on définit pas ce
que ça veut dire parce que les adultes
évidemment vous mangez chocolat vont
vont consommer des friandises mais ça
veut dire quoi
donc il le cadre est de vente actuel
n'est pas clair donc ce que je comprends
ceux qui encore pas mal de travail à
train parce qu'il ya quand même il faut
penser aux risques pour les plus jeunes
sylvain charlebois
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin et encore une fois bonne année
2010 9 plusieurs nouvelles
alimentaire à suivre on en rediscutera
certainement à faire voir au revoir